esperaban encontrar seguridad en
pakistán pero esta familia afgana
todavía no ve el fin de sus problemas
los 38 integrantes de la familia huyeron
de la guerra en la provincia de helmand
y llegaron a pakistán a través del cruce
chamán
ahora viven en una tienda medio
derrumbada
la guerra era feroz huimos de la guerra
con nuestros hijos dejando atrás
nuestras casas nuestro ganado nuestras
pertenencias y entramos a pakistán para
trasladarla está más aquí estamos entre
ruinas y tiendas deshechas
caribú del bagre
las autoridades paquistaníes aseguran
que sus fronteras están cerradas a todos
los que no tengan los papeles en regla
pero centenares de afganos han cruzado
por el pasaje de samán más al norte hay
otro punto de entrada pakistán en thor
ham del lado afgano este punto está
resguardado por los soldados talibanes
mientras que el lado paquistaní también
ha aumentado su seguridad
oficialmente hay 14 millones de
refugiados afganos en pakistán islamabad
quiere evitar un fenómeno de migración
masiva
durante los últimos años pakistán ha
construido una valla de 4 metros de
altura para reforzar una frontera porosa
y protegerse de la inestabilidad de sus
vecinos
las naciones unidas ha advertido que
medio millón de afganos podrían dejar su
país hasta final de año y si no llega
más ayuda humanitaria la situación
podría empeorar